Joshua understand that you initially
made the act of killing to tell the
victims or the survivors story of the
Indonesian genocide but then things took
a turn you tell us what happened yeah I
began this project in collaboration with
a community of survivors and every time
we would film together every time we
would try and talk about what happened
in 1965 the military would come and stop
us I would be arrested our crew would be
arrested our equipment would be taken we
would be detained and it was impossible
really to get anything done and at the
same time some of the survivors with
whom I was living in this canoe in this
community it was in a plantation about
60 miles from the city of Maya Don where
I made the act of killing they would
send me on these missions they would
send us to go film with a neighbor who
they suspected or knew was a perpetrator
and thought would know for example how a
loved one had been killed how one woman
sent us to try and find out how her son
was killed someone else how her aunt was
killed and we would go on these kind of
missions on behalf of the survivors to
find out what had happened and
encountered these perpetrators who
within minutes of meeting them would
boast about how they'd killed why they
about how they killed the details of how
they killed and sometimes we find out
how people's relatives had died and it
was I realized then this was this
extraordinary situation it was as though
I walked into Nazi Germany 40 years
after the Holocaust and the Nazis were
still in power the survivors too afraid
to speak not allowed to speak the
perpetrators at least unofficially
encouraged a boast about what they had
done so that they would be these kind of
feared proxies of the state and I and I
felt I remember feeling this situation
is so important so not extraordinary but
important that it demands that I give
whatever it takes and now it's about a
decade on from I and I've just finished
this film there was - we were there was
this moment where the
once we was clear we couldn't really
film with the survivors where we went
back we took a trip to Jakarta to meet
the Indonesian human rights community
which we hadn't met yet with the
survivors and we asked is this still too
sensitive this history is it too
dangerous to make this film everybody
said no you're onto something terribly
important
we need a film for Indonesians that
exposes essentially what everybody
already knows but is it too afraid to
say so we need a film that comes like
the child and the emperor's new clothes
and says look the king is naked
everybody knew it but it's too afraid to
say it but hopefully after it's exposed
by this movie people will be able to
talk about what happened and reassess
look at what look at what happened but
also look at the nature of a regime of
impunity of corruption a fear that's
been built essentially on mass graves so
we talk okay how can we do this safely
and then one of the survivors said
continue to film the perpetrators
because they boast you've seen that and
in their boasting the audience will see
exactly why we're so afraid and the
nature of this regime so I started to
film every perpetrator I could find
across the region up the chain of
command to the city of Madonn where I
made the act of killing and beyond two
army generals retired living in Jakarta
and found that everybody I filmed was
open within minutes of meeting them they
would tell me these horrific stories of
how they killed and then right after
telling me how they killed often in
front of their grandchildren their wives
their children they would suggest that
they take me to the places where they
killed
I would accept those invitations and
then they would launch into these sort
of spontaneous demonstrations of how
they killed and complain afterwards that
they hadn't thought to bring props they
hadn't thought to bring machetes to use
as props or friends to play victims and
I was the questions in my head started
to shift from what happened historically
which I was quickly understanding to
what is happening now in what the
perpetrators want to be seen this way
why are they boasting about this for
whom are they boasting what's the
function of this boasting how do they
think I hear it how do they want their
society to see them how do they want the
whole
to see them and how ultimately do they
see themselves and really in pursuit of
answers to those questions I proposed
the following very openly to all of the
men I was filming look you've
participated in one of the biggest
killings in human history
your whole society is based on it your
lives are shaped by it you want to show
me what you've done I want to understand
what it means to you in your society so
show me what you've done in whatever way
you want I'll film the process I'll film
the reenactments and with that material
I'll try and answer these questions what
does it mean to you what does it mean to
your society how do you want to be seen
how do you see yourself and that's what
I did
you